[Musik]
liebe gemeinde wer aber ganz ohne
populismus ist der werfe den ersten
döner so heißt es im brief des apostel
horse an die beschränkten der islam
gehört nicht zu deutschland das finden
76 prozent der deutschen
dabei erfüllen wir eine total wichtige
funktion als feindbild ohne uns wäre die
afc innerhalb von sekunden erledigt es
gebe keine talkshows und horst seehofer
käme sofort ins heim
die muslime ist es natürlich schwierig
die forderung umzusetzen
man sagt uns ihr gehört nicht dazu ihr
werdet nie dazugehören aber ihr müsst
euch gefälligst integrieren da merkt
sogar dass ausländer das ist unlogisch
das ist so als würde mir der türsteher
sagen du kommst hier nicht rein aber du
musst mit tanzen
in wirklichkeit geht es gar nicht um
religion im kern ist das hier das
problem wenn sie die straße gehen egal
in welcher stadt links oder rechts zu
hören keine deutsche stimme mehr
nehmen sie hören nur noch [ __ ]
gequatsche ja da sind wir ein stück weit
auch selber schuld liebe mit [ __ ]
lasst uns endlich aufhören mit diesem
paar sacken gequatsche und lasst uns
damit aufhören so penetrant anders
auszusehen und lasst uns akzeptieren
dass deutschland ein weltliches land ist
religion und staat sind strikt getrennt
deswegen werden ja auch um meinen
steuern die gehälter von evangelischen
und katholischen bischöfen bezahlt was
sehen wir es positiv
offensichtlich gehöre ich nicht zu
deutschland aber mein steuergeld schon
immerhin ein anfang und nun liebe von
überfremdung angst gebeutelte gemeinde
schlagen wir unsere gesangbücher auf und
singen lied nummer 214 schicke dem
schicken
[Musik]
[Applaus]